-Longtime Trump ally
Chris Christie is
on a media rehabilitation tour,
ahead of a possible run
for president in 2024,
while the man he helped
catapult into office
is still spreading
the same unhinged lies
about the election, this time,
and an interview
with Mike Lindell.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
If you've been watching CNN
or MSNBC lately,
it seems like there's been
one person, in particular,
who's been more ubiquitous
than ever.
-We've spent the past hour
on Chris Christie
and what it's like to be him.
-Still ahead on "Morning Joe,"
former New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie.
-Former governor of New Jersey
Chris Christie
will join the conversation.
-When we come back,
Chris Christie.
-Joining us now,
former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie.
-Joining us now,
the aforementioned
Chris Christie.
-We're back with former
New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie.
-Chris Christie joins me now.
-Former Republican governor
of New Jersey
Chris Christie.
-I mean, at this point,
Christie's on cable news
so much,
they're going
to start putting him
in a tiny box
in the corner of the screen.
[ Laughter ]
"And let's check in
on our Christie Cam.
[ Laughter ]
Oh! Looks like he's arguing
with a stagehand about the Jets.
Let's see how this plays out."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, my God,
he's been on cable news
more often than
the reverse mortgage commercials
starring Tom Selleck.
[ Laughter ]
At least do us the courtesy
of growing the mustache,
Christie!
[ Laughter ]
Also, damn you, Selleck,
and your silver tongue!
[ Laughter ]
I took out a reverse mortgage,
thinking I'd score
some quick cash,
and, now, Tom Selleck lives
in my house
with my wife and kids!
[ Laughter ]
In fact, he's doing
the reverse mortgage commercials
from my attic!
[ Laughter ]
And, even worse,
he's best friends
with the Sea Captain now.
[ Laughter ]
-Love me some Selleck.
He's my favorite of the
"Three Men and a Baby."
Sorry, Guttenberg.
[ Laughter ]
True story --
every night, I do a Q&A
with the audience,
and, every night,
at least one person says,
"Bring back the Sea Captain,"
and then, the rest
of the audience
just starts chucking rocks
at whoever said it.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, all I can think is,
"Where did everybody get
loose rocks in New York?"
[ Laughter ]
Anyway...
[ Ding ]
...cable is so desperate
to fill time
that CNN even aired a ludicrous
special focused entirely
on Christie, called...
Is it called that
because "Being" is
the only title he has left?
[ Laughter ]
Governor? No, he left office
with a dismal approval rating.
Candidate? Oh, no.
He crashed and burned hard
in the GOP primary.
But, he is still,
technically, a being.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm sorry,
but is there a mystery
to being Chris Christie?
You guys are acting like
he's some
weird-lifestyle-having guy
like everybody wants
to know about.
He's not Harry Styles or Banksy.
He's a loudmouth
from New Jersey.
If you want to know
what he's thinking,
you don't need CNN.
You just have to be
within earshot,
[ Laughter ]
which is for him, I think,
like a mile?
[ Laughter ]
In fact, if this show
was authentic New Jersey,
it wouldn't be called
"Being Chris Christie."
It'd be called...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
The only way I'd be interested
in a show called
"Being Chris Christie" is
if I could enter his head,
"Being John Malkovich"-style,
and make him do something
embarrassing, like,
I don't know, stand
behind someone who hates him.
Oh, right, you know,
he did that.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, I'd make him
sit alone on a closed beach.
Oh, he did that, too.
[ Laughter ]
You know what? Never mind.
Now, let's just establish,
right off the bat,
that Chris Christie is
without credibility,
when it comes to Trump.
He repeatedly said he wasn't
suited to be president,
that he didn't have
the temperament
or experience for the job.
Then, he became one of the first
prominent Republicans
to endorse him in 2016.
Then, he stood by him
throughout his presidency
and even helped him prep
for that first debate in 2020,
where Trump yelled nonstop
for 90 minutes,
like a caller
on a sports radio show
who shouts over Mike Francesa.
[ New Jersey accent ]
No, no, Mike,
you don't understand.
Excuse me, Mike.
It's good that the Mets
let Syndergaard go.
Excuse me because Jacob deGrom
is never injured.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's nice,
when the Mets are in the news,
to [bleep]
so we can take a break
from making fun of the Jets,
but it is true --
Noah Syndergaard, who was here,
on this show, not too long ago,
is now a Los Angeles Angel.
And, when he was here,
he certainly acted
like he was going to be
a Met for life.
There were some signs,
like, when I said,
"Hey, maybe we can get dinner
when the season starts,"
he said, "U..."
[ Laughter ]
...m...
maybe?"
So, your nickname
might be Thor, but to me,
you're a Loki.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding ]
Christie was so deeply invested
in getting Trump
elected president
and keeping him in office
that he helped prep him
for that [bleep]show debate,
where Trump was so insane
and unhinged
that the moderator had to keep
shouting the word no at him
like a dog who wouldn't stop
humping his owner's leg.
-I'll ask Joe. The individual --
-No.
-Did you get a half million?
-No! Hey, Mr. President.
-Which was heavily --
-No. Mr. President.
No, no, go ahead.
No, no, no.
Mr. President. Mr. President.
-$3.5 million, Joe.
$3.5 million.
-No, no, no.
No, Mr. President.
-Go ahead.
-No!
-Can I be honest?
It's a very important question.
-Try to be honest.
-No.
-It'd be good for you.
-He stood up.
[ Laughter ]
He stood up
-No. The answer
to the question is no.
-and he threatened --
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, the only way
I want to hear from Christie is
if he told us
he was a double agent trying
to destroy Trump's campaign
from the inside.
[ As Christie ]
Yeah, I helped him prep
for the debate,
told him issues were for losers
and made him snort
half a dozen Pixy Stix.
[ Laughter ]
But Christie was a key part
of the debate prep.
In fact,
according to a new book...
[ Laughter ]
First of all, there's never been
a worse casting choice
[ Laughter ]
for the role of Joe Biden
than Chris Christie.
Biden's a soft-talking grandpa
from Delaware,
and Christie's
a New Jersey bully
with the temperament
of a seagull
attacking a beach blanket
in Atlantic City.
[ Laughter ]
It's like if they couldn't
get Tom Hanks
to play Sully Sullenberger
and, instead,
went with Al Pacino.
[ As Pacino ]
Whoa, buckle up, muchacho!
We are going down!
[ Laughter ]
We got hit by a loose goose.
This is your captain, Sully.
Isn't it weird?
If you had the last name
Sullenberger,
would you name your kid Sully?
[ Laughter ]
It's a nickname?
What's his real --
Chesley?!
[ Laughter ]
But the reason Trump
apparently blew up at Christie
during that debate prep session
was because Trump was obsessed
with all the nonsense
conspiracy theories
Rudy Giuliani was pushing
about Biden and his family.
So, Christie,
playing the part of Biden,
brought up Trump's own
conflicts of interest
to prep him
for Biden's response.
[ Laughter ]
At one point,
Trump said to Christie...
I'm not going to sit here
and put up with it.
Alright, first of all,
I love that,
while they were trying
to prepare the president
for a nationally
televised debate,
Rudy was sitting there
distracting everyone,
trying to get his iPad to work.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
My iPad keeps freezing.
"Rudy, that's not an iPad.
That's a picture frame."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
That can't be right.
I got it from my IT guy,
Michael.
[ Laughter ]
Now, as you may know,
not only was that debate prep
a disaster,
just in terms of the debate
itself, but, on top of that,
Christie and a bunch
of other people in the room
got COVID from it
and, even then,
Trump apparently had no concern,
whatsoever,
for Christie's well-being.
In fact, in his new book...
[ Laughter ]
He's talking about COVID
like Christie's RA just found
a bag of weed
in his sock drawer.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Are you gonna say
you got it from me, Chris?
Because I'm already
on thin ice with the dean.
[ Laughter ]
And, yet, despite the fact
that debate prep was a disaster
and he got yelled at by Trump
and that he was complicit in
and actively supportive of
a catastrophic
and deeply corrupt presidency
that, among other things,
subverted our democracy,
let a deadly respiratory disease
spiral wildly out of control,
and cratered our economy,
Christie said he really
only had one regret
about his participation.
-In the last days
of the Trump administration,
The New Yorker published a Q&A
with you,
with the headline
"Chris Christie Has No Regrets."
Really?
-I really don't.
Look, Mike --
-You don't regret
prepping Donald Trump
for his bid
to run for reelection?
-I do not.
I do not.
The only regret I have
about that is that --
-Some people --
-The only regret I have
about that is
I caught COVID
when I was doing it.
[ Laughter ]
-It's pretty great
when you're trying to see
if a person has
a guilty conscience
and their only regret is --
[ As Christie ] I got sick.
[ Laughter ]
It's like a judge
asking a drunk driver
if he has anything to say
before sentencing and they yell,
"Just that no one seems to care
that my Camaro's
all scratched up!"
[ Laughter ]
So, now, Christie's trying
to rehab his image
as part of a book tour,
by casting himself as some sort
of straight shooter,
when it comes
to the 2020 election.
Look, I guess, at this point,
any Republican
who's willing to say
the election wasn't stolen
deserves a shred of credit,
which tells you just how far
the GOP has fallen.
But, why are we taking
Chris Christie,
of all people, seriously?
He stood by
this obviously monstrous man
for years
and he still refuses to say
whether he'd support Trump again
in 2024.
-Donald Trump has made it
pretty clear
he wants to run
for president again.
Would you support him?
-Oh, look, I don't know
that he's going to run.
-What if he does.
-I don't know
if I'm going to run.
Oh, look, "What if?"
I've learned --
-I mean, it's not as if
it's a big secret that he's
seriously considering it.
-He's seriously considering it.
Let's see what happens
when he does
and let's see who he is
and what he says
and how he conducts himself.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yes, let's see
which Donald Trump will show up.
Will it be the well-spoken
and serious statesman,
or will it be the one
who exists?
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know,
the being Donald Trump.
I'm sorry, you still think
there's a mystery
as to how Donald Trump
is going to conduct himself?
Having kids,
I've read a lot of books
about what to expect
at different stages,
but not one of them has said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's especially ludicrous
to claim you don't know
how Trump will conduct himself
when, as we speak,
he's still spreading the big lie
that Christie supposedly
criticizes him for.
Trump just did an interview
with MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell,
where he and Lindell competed
for worst posture
[ Laughter ]
and rambled on
about the same old
election conspiracy theories.
And, by the way,
Christie has no credibility,
especially when it comes
to questions
about the 2020 election
because he repeatedly insisted,
in the run-up to the election,
that Trump would
accept the result,
even though Trump was loudly
proclaiming, at the time,
that the only way he could lose
is if it was stolen.
-You know this guy well.
Do you believe he would
follow critical conventions
in the United States
and have a peaceful transition
of power
for those months
between this election result
and the next inauguration?
-There's no question in my mind
that President Trump
will participate in a peaceful
transition of power,
if he does not win
tomorrow night.
-If it doesn't go
the president's way --
you know him pretty well --
is he prepared to accept defeat?
-Yes.
Yeah, I think he is.
I think there also is part
of him that knows
that not leaving
the White House,
putting up that kind of stink,
in terms of peaceful transition,
just is not the way
he wants to leave.
-I'm sorry, you thought Trump
wouldn't put up a stink?
That's all he ever does,
put up a stink.
If he had his own line
of deodorant,
that would be the tagline.
[ Laughter ]
For the life of me,
I can't understand
why the media
is willingly participating
in the rehabilitation
of a guy like Chris Christie.
He was a central figure
in the rise
of an obviously
horrendous president
who left the nation in ruins.
He shouldn't get a chance
to launder his reputation
ahead of another
presidential run,
with reporters
following him around,
asking him what he thinks.
The only two things that
should follow Christie around
are support for Trump and...
-A stink.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.